AND HE HAS
THE BEST BURGER IN TOWN.
- I HAVE THE BEST BURGERS
IN L.A.
- SO I PAID HIM A VISIT
WITH A WAY
TO GET EVERYONE
TO TRY HIS BURGER.
MY PLAN WAS A GUARANTEE:
TRY THE BURGER,
AND IF YOU DON'T THINK
IT'S THE BEST IN L.A.,
GUSTAVO WILL GIVE YOU
$100 CASH OF HIS OWN MONEY.
- I DON'T KNOW.
- IT IS THE BEST, RIGHT?
- IT'S THE BEST.
- OKAY, GREAT.
SO THEN WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
- WELL,
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE--
- UNLESS YOUR BURGER
ISN'T THE BEST.
- UH, WELL, UM--
- WAIT,
IS YOUR BURGER THE BEST?
- OF COURSE,
IT'S THE BEST.
- 'CAUSE NO BURGER PLACE
HAS EVER MADE A CLAIM LIKE THIS,
BUT YOU CAN,
'CAUSE YOU'RE THE BEST.
- WELL,
IT SOUNDS GOOD.
- YEAH
- IT SOUNDS GOOD.
- GUSTAVO AGREED TO PUT UP
HIS OWN CASH FOR THE PROMOTION,
AND IT WAS
SUCH AN AMAZING OFFER,
THAT I WAS EASILY ABLE
TO LAND US
ON L.A.'S MOST LISTENED-TO
MORNING RADIO SHOW.
- [radio announcer]
95.5 KLOS.
- COME OVER,
TRY OUR--OUR BURGERS.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT,
IT'S GONNA BE $100 BILL.
- WOW, THAT'S IMPRESSIVE.
- THAT'S--
THAT'S A LOT OF BALLS,
GUSTAVO...
- YEAH.
- 100 BUCKS, 'CAUSE I MEAN,
AREN'T YOU--I MEAN,
WHEN'S THIS PROMOTION HAPPENING?
- IT'S GONNA HAPPEN TODAY AT--
- TODAY?
- YEAH.
- I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR
HOW IT TURNS OUT. OKAY.
- ALL FAITH, ALL RIGHT.
- AND I TRUST HIM,
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T ACTUALLY
TRIED THE BURGER.
I DON'T EAT RED MEAT
RIGHT NOW.
- WHAT?
- SO I MEAN,
WHEN HE SAYS IT'S THE BEST,
I--YOU KNOW,
I BELIEVE THAT IT'S THE BEST.
- OKAY.
- CAN I ASK,
HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE LISTENING RIGHT NOW?
both: MILLIONS.
- MILLIONS?
- YEAH.
- MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
ARE LISTENING TO THIS RIGHT NOW,
GUSTAVO.
- THAT'S CRAZY.
- YEAH, THAT IS.
- LET'S GO TO FREDDY
ON LINE TWO.
HELLO, FREDDY. WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF THIS PROMOTIONAL IDEA
THAT L.A. BURGER'S
THROWING ON.
- I THINK
IT'S A TERRIBLE IDEA.
LET ME TELL YOU MY BACKGROUND,
FIRST OF ALL--
- WELL, I--WHO CARES
ABOUT YOUR BACKGROUND, FREDDY?
[laughter]
ALL RIGHT, NEXT CALLER, PLEASE.
- STEVE ON LINE TWO.
HELLO, STEVE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF THIS IDEA?
- WELL, I ADMIRE, YOU KNOW,
HIM STANDING BY HIS PRODUCT,
BUT I THINK
THAT SOMEBODY CAN BE DISHONEST
AND LIE ABOUT THE BURGER.
THEY CAN JUST SAY, "YOU KNOW,
I'VE HAD OTHER BURGERS
I THINK ARE BETTER."
- I COULD SEE THAT GUSTAVO
WAS GETTING NERVOUS
DURING THE RADIO SHOW,
SO AFTER,
I HAD A TALK WITH HIM.
- SO I SAW YOU WERE
A LITTLE BIT NERVOUS IN THERE.
- UM, A LITTLE.
[chuckles]
- WELL, I DON'T WANT THIS TO BE
A STRESSFUL EXPERIENCE FOR YOU,
SO I'LL TELL YOU WHAT,
EVEN THOUGH IT'S UNLIKELY
I THINK PEOPLE
WILL CLAIM THE $100,
I'LL PERSONALLY PUT UP
MY OWN MONEY IF THEY DO,
BUT IT'S ONLY BECAUSE
I TRUST YOU
WHEN YOU SAY IT'S THE BEST.
IT IS THE BEST, RIGHT?
- IT IS THE BEST, YES.
- SO WE WON'T
BE PAYING A LOT.
- WE'RE NOT GONNA PAY
THAT MUCH MONEY...AT ALL.
- OKAY, SO NO RISK ON YOU,
IT'S ALL ON ME.
both: [laugh]